moonlight is directed by Barry Jenkins
it is the story of young shyrone and
it's broken up into three separate acts
the first act is him as a young boy
the second is him as a young man in
school and the third is him as a
full-blown adult and this film shows in
great and excruciating detail how young
shyrone can grow up in a very harsh
environment and how he can eventually
become an adult in a world that doesn't
quite understand who he begins to
realize he is look I'm just gonna come
out and say this this film floored me it
flattened me to the ground this is
easily one of the best films of the year
there isn't a single shot in this movie
that feels misplaced I saw this film
over a week ago and I've been thinking
about it ever since then and I cannot
find a single thing that's out of place
with this film this is a masterwork when
the movie boyhood came out and everyone
was declaring that it was the best film
ever and that it explored youth and
growing up in such an amazing way I saw
it and I liked it but overall I was
disappointed with boyhood moonlight is
everything that I wanted boyhood to be
and I respect boyhood this film is
fucking amazing this is a stunningly
intimate movie that so beautifully
examines how hard it can be for someone
to grow up in an environment that
doesn't understand him
this kid shyrone at a very young age
begins to discover things about himself
that he doesn't quite understand and no
one else around him seems to understand
either he feels more at ease talking to
this man played by Maher saleh ali
because he doesn't have a father figure
in his life and his mother played by
Naomi Harris is kind of a drug addict
and so he finds people that he can feel
semi comfortable around and as he gets
older in the film that becomes
increasingly more difficult for him
because he just feels so separated from
everyone else around him I haven't seen
a film in years that so perfectly
captures the harsh urban environment
that a lot of kids these days grow up in
without resorting to all of the cliches
of these types of movies and it's filmed
in such a raw way with camera
that is so fascinating it never lets you
out of its grasp all three of the actors
that portray shyrone are incredible in
this movie the performances are so good
in this film that they're almost too
good to be true I kept waiting for
someone to wake me up because I was
watching this movie and it was just so
damn good and I was waiting for
something to fall over I was waiting for
some horrible subplot or some really
boring element I was waiting for one of
the three acts to be stupid anything I
was just like is anything gonna be bad
my god everything's great because I'm so
used to seeing movies like this where I
feel like everything is so good and then
they make a really dumb choice because
they're trying to be risky that never
happens in this movie and I was so
pleased to discover what the film is
really about because I didn't know going
in and for that reason I'm not going to
ruin it for you here I loved watching
shyrone discover things about himself I
loved watching him go through a journey
that was emotional for him but I also
really loved one specific aspect of this
movie this is an all-black cast and what
I love about it is that I have never
seen a film that goes through this
specific storytelling beat of how a
black man might grow up in a very harsh
environment discovering things that in
his environment are very abnormal and
that a lot of people just don't accept
and he has to learn how to live with
that and how to appreciate that side of
him
this film is stunningly mature beautiful
everything about it I loved the
performances especially towards the end
feels so real the scenes towards the end
of this film as the film draws to a
close
felt so in the moment I genuinely felt
like I was watching something real just
unfolding in front of me and that's
because of masterful Direction perfect
editing and performances that are
unanimously across the board award
worthy everyone in this film shines
everything in this film shines it's
easily one of the best films of the year
and I'm going to stop talking about it
because I don't want to give away
anything I think
you all should go see moonlight I think
it's amazing and moonlight absolutely
deserves an A+ guys I can't tell you how
happy it was to see a film so well
realized to see this vision so well
obtained on the screen and to see a film
that does have a message without feeling
like I'm being pounded into the ground
with it guys thank you so much as always
for watching definitely seek out
moonlight if you can find in the theater
near you and as always if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes
you